if you've driven along las vegas
boulevard you probably noticed a lot of
construction those detour signs and
those orange cones the city recently
announced that the project in that area
is almost done and with that comes a big
sigh of relief for commuters and
business owners in the area madison
kimbrough joins us live tonight near
oakey and las vegas boulevard with the
details madison
according to the city construction here
on las vegas boulevard is about 80
percent complete take a look as those
who work visit or live around the area
say it couldn't come soon enough now the
construction project has been in years
in the making and its focus is on
improving the 2.5 mile stretch from
stuart to sahara avenue that includes
roads near fremont street all the way to
the strip however with it comes massive
congestion and road headaches for
commuters while disrupting foot traffic
at the same time also limiting parking
for those that want to go to their
favorite stores or restaurants we
stopped by a popular restaurant viva las
arepas to hear how the construction has
impacted them so far
i lost a lot of business yeah and also
besides that was a lot of like dusty you
know
the parking is way too small now it's
only they take like eight spaces from
the front
and now with the marijuana dispenser
it's gonna be more crowd you know
because a lot of people come in to buy
marijuana
[Music]
now it's still unknown when the
construction will be a hundred percent
complete but if you drive down las vegas
boulevard you can already tell there
will be more room for cars and people
along with smoother roads to drive on
now as always if you are headed down
this way take your time and leave early
to get to your destination destination
as detours and roadblocks will be in
place so make sure that you take your
time so you can get to your destination
safely reporting live on las vegas
boulevard madison kimbrough live local
now